I'm uh being uh 10:02 we will open up
our long range Capital planning and
utilization
committee um and start with U accept a
motion to accept the minutes of May 26
and September 1st Mr chairman I move
acceptance of the September 1st 2023
minutes thank you uh seconded
by
okay seconded okay motion made clear air
second by Mills um all those uh any
discussion on those minutes Corrections
omissions seeing none if you're in favor
of uh the minutes of May 26 and
September 1st is distributed signified
by saying I
I any
opposed
um abstain you want to come up further
here I just I just don't know that Mike
we get you on video over there wouldn't
opportunity thank you
um we will move on to um first item on
on our
agenda item
23022 Department of
Transportation excuse me Mr chairman do
we also the minutes of May 26 have we've
done that because I thought I just made
a motion for September 1st oh I'm sorry
I was looking for a motion for both both
I sorry I didn't okay so we have motion
I move the accept the minutes of May 26
that's sorry about that oh that's okay
I'll second all right motion been made
in second May 26 I apologize for passing
over that um any uh omissions or changes
required seeing none if you're in favor
of the motion to accept the minutes of
May 26 please signify by saying I
I um any
opposed um unanimous okay thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh thank you Mr Vice
chair for catching
that uh move on to the first
um first item on our busy agenda here uh
lrcp
2322 uh brought by the Department of
Transportation convey a permanent
easement access easement across state
owned land parcel located 36 hor Pond
Road and with that the department please
introduce
yourself thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee uh my name is Steve
leonti I'm the administrator of the
Bureau of RightWay within the Hampshire
Department of
Transportation um in item 22 the
department requests to Grant a 50 foot
wide permanent access easement across
three Parcels of state-owned land to 36
Hors Point Road in the town of Belmont
we're asking that the committee um allow
us to Grant this easement uh at no cost
to the grantee and to wave the $1,100
administrative fee the purpose of which
is this is really housekeeping item back
in the 70s the department started to
acquire property uh to build the
Franklin Laconia
bypass um abing this land and from the
grante predecessor and interest the
apartment the department acquired
property which then severed the subject
parcel or the grante parcel from Route
three uh to remedy this we allowed the
uh the property owner to to still use an
existing gravel driveway across the
corridor and this this um permission was
immortalized in the late 90s with I
believe what was an access agreement or
an encroachment agreement which was
subsequently recorded in the bellnap
County registry of
deeds and uh the intent of that was at a
later point when the road was built if
this would grant them um we would grant
them a permanent access easement and
this was in the encroachment agreement
we would grant them a permanent access
easement onto the new Corridor and at
any point in the future if the town
built the beach access road which it has
since which it since has at the
Department's expense we would um build
an access road to the beach access road
from the grantees parcel uh and that was
to um make the property owner whole from
having to go through the time and
expense of building an access point to
the new road um and for the safety of
the traveling public moving that the
department would incur that so because
the road was never built the property
owner never had to go through that time
and expense but now they're asking for
the um access to be to the beach Road
and that's best and that best serves the
traveling public at that point that's
why we're asking to Grant it at no cost
it's just basically cleaning up the
paperwork removing this will this will
void the temporary encroachment and
access agreement and inl give the uh
property owner access over the three
state Parcels to their parcel thank you
are there questions yes sender L move to
approve uh motion motion by Senator Lang
to approve is there a second second by
Mills um any further
discussion this whole this whole project
seems very familiar to me so Deja right
yeah so um all right so motion's been
made uh to
23022 call the rooll or we do just a
motion Voice vote if you're in favor of
the motion signified by saying I I any
you we will la will'll move on to um L
lrcp
23025 Department of Transportation
disposal of two parcel State own land um
105 South Main Street seon AB city of
conquer if you would sir thank you Mr
chairman uh the department requests uh
authorization to dispose of the two
mentioned Parcels of land at South Main
Street and section Avenue in the city of
conquered uh the two Parcels of un now
unimproved land I believe they were
improved when the department purchased
them back in the early 80s um the two
the two Parcels together uh combined are
67 of an acre and the parcels were
acquired for the construction of the
store Street Extension uh the department
has this this whole sale was initiated
by um interest from a developer uh the
parcels are regularly shaped with
limited access um although they are
considered uh independently marketable
we thought that they would probably it
was a broader Market if we combined the
two parcels and sold them together happy
to take any other questions all right
any questions for uh
Monte seeing none um motion move to
approve um motion to approved by Sor
Lang second and by
second
discussion if you're if you're in favor
of the motion uh lrcp
23025 signified by saying I I I any
carries so that's we move on to um lrcp
23026 Department of
Transportation authorize uh
authorization to convey a permanent
right at easement over state-owned land
located in Dober at no cost to the city
of Dober if you would
sir thank you Mr chairman uh this is
again another housekeeping item so this
what we're asking to do is basically
transfer an existing drainage easement
owned by the state of New Hampshire and
acquired as part of the Newington do
project um and it's off Doo Road
acquired for that project we're asking
to at no cost and to wave the
administrative fee to transfer that
easement to the city of Dober the uh
drain eement serves local roads mainly
do Point Road and which is in the
current which is in the
um which is in the process of being
reclassified to a local Road uh so the
department purchased it back in
2013 while the uh project was active and
paid $500 for it again by transferring
this it relieves the department of the
burden of maintaining the easement and
the liability that goes along with
it move to approve I'll second that
motion a motion made by Senator Lang
seconded by represent cluder to approve
the
motion um any
um any further
discussion if you're in favor of the
23026 I believe is where we're at
correct you'll signify thank you signify
by saying I I any
unanimously we'll move on to item lrcp
23027 Department of
Transportation uh request authorization
to sell 6.8 three acres of state owned
land located Wesley s of North local
$500,000 uh if you would sir thank you
Mr chairman um the department had
received an inquiry from the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
about this parcel this parcel was
purchased as um purchased as part of the
North Conway bypass however it was used
to build the north south local Road
um so it was a participating land as far
as the Federal Highway was
concerned um what uh the parcel is made
up of
6.83 acres and is combined several uh
Parcels of land uh total the department
paid
$396,500
uh since we have uh submitted this item
um the town has shown some interest in
the parcel
as well so we
believe uh this parcel will be sold
whether it's to the town of Conway or
the New Hampshire Housing Authority we
doubt that it will actually reach the
open market the New Hampshire Housing
Authority has uh implied that it wants
to use or Express that it wants to use
the property for affordable housing uh
the Hampshire uh the town of Conway has
um expressed that they have some other
uses for it as well or some interest in
other uses for it as well so I can
answer any other
questions question before are you going
to call for a motion no question yes
please so so that right now it's your
request is in either or either the town
or New Hampshire Finance Authority if it
doesn't go to either of those will you
be back here to put it on the open
market or is this also a motion to put
it on the open market if those two fall
through well that's a good that's a good
question that that I'll be C that I
haven't considered yet I would think we
would have to come back to get approval
for the realtor we use on the open
you um further
questions repres please Chet from the
LBA I'm not sure they would necessarily
have to come back what the committee is
doing is providing the department the
authority to dispose of the land the
first step is to see if the city or town
that the land's located in would want it
then they would move forward with the
how they would go about a disposal they
also go through governor and counsel
through that process so I I'm not sure
that they would have to come back they
could come back as an informational just
to let you know that
um what they hadn't told you might
happen isn't actually going to happen
there's something else that you know
they're going to put it through a
realtor and then sell it that way but I
just wanted to clarify that because what
you're providing Authority for is to
dispose of the property not how they
dispose of it because in the statute it
has the the mechanism that they're to
follow yep followup Senator well again
my question was because I know on 25 we
just approved it was specific to a
realtor that was in in in The Proposal
about disposing of the land in conquer
and so that's why I was asking a
question where this is like no we're g
to give it to it's going to be sold
specifically to the town but they don't
re that's all I was that's why I was
asking well the the approval you made on
that previous item is is again to
dispose of the land what the department
has provided is additional information
as to how they were going to go about
that process they're going to use a
realtor because they don't have somebody
that was going to buy it right off you
know already decided they didn't have
somebody that wanted to purchase it but
they do know they want to get rid of the
property but again I just wanted to
clarify that the authority of the
committee is just to allow the the
agency to dispose of the property the
other information is there for the
committee to as they make their decision
on whether they want to let the dispose
the
property thank you Mr Shay if I if I
could U come back with a question on
the uh the value of this land the five
$500,000 is that is that a full market
value as as uh as outlined as determined
by our internal appraiser yes okay so if
if I could follow so uh New Hampshire
Housing Authority uh which uh for
Workforce housing I'm suppor of if the
town were to make make the offer but and
if if neither of those went through and
we gave the authority
and then it went for disposal I just
want to make sure that's a real value
and that we haven't cut the value for
that property so how this would work is
again if it went that route we're
probably talking a year or two away from
now so what we would end up doing is we
would go to we would put out requesting
market analysis with the Realtors from
that region they would come in with
various numbers uh we would would
analyze those numbers internally and
pick our realtor based not always on the
highest number but what we think is the
most realistic so it's a chance that
number would change meaning likely it's
GNA only go up right but um is's a
chance that number would change but go
up so okay Senator fine with that yeah
I'm fine with that again I know I know
Conway's in desperate need of housing
right now so I'm completely okay with
this and if you're ready for a motion
I'll make yes I am move to approve uh
motion by Senator Lang to approve and
seconded by uh represent CL uh any
further
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion uh lrcp
23027 signified by saying I I if you're
opposed seeing none passes
unanimously we'll move on to item 23028
a request to sell 5.93 Acres state-owned
land improvements uh 95 Common Court
Town of Conway for one looks like $1
million uh with that
please thank you Mr chairman similar to
the last item this property was
purchased um and used to build the north
south Road in Conway again we were
approached by the New Hampshire Housing
Finance
Authority um who expressed interest in
using the property for affordable
housing property consists of 5.93 Acres
it currently has two condo style
buildings um two existing condo
buildings were in much better shape plus
there were other buildings that were
raised to make room for the north south
road so that's why you're seeing a
different we we were buying improved
land where now we have two buildings
that I I don't believe uh necessarily
give much value to the property um so
that's why you're seeing the difference
in value there on what we're asking and
what thank you any
questions move to approve um motion to
approve by Senator Lang seconded by
second represent cluder any further
question before we I did have one more
followup or clarify yes please so the
difference between the 1.3 that we
bought it at and the 1.04 we're selling
it at is a there was some land shaved
off to make way for the roadway in
addition there were additional roads
that were on there so it's a little bit
smaller parcel and there's less
buildings on it it's it's a smaller
parcel and virtually unimproved thank
you
okay uh seeing no further questions if
you're in favor of the motion for 23028
signified by saying I I I any opposed
seeing none motion
carries slon perhaps at another time uh
the department I don't know if it'd be
appropriate by you or the department and
maybe back to public works or here to
tell us where we are with our uh
obligations to the feds on uh lands
disposing of for the bypass for
convite I can I either myself or another
represent
can can do that another time next year
please um we will move on now to
um item um
23029 requests authorization to convey a
permanent right of easement state owned
land located in Dober at no cost to the
city of Dober with that
please thank you Mr chairman um this is
almost an identical request to the one
we we we discussed a few items ago again
it was part of the Newington it was
acquired as part of the Newington Dober
project it serves uh local roads as uh
in Dober Point Road which is going
through a reclassification at this point
uh the dep Department purchased this
easement in
2013 for
$750 we asked to transfer it to the city
of Dober at no cost um which will then
again um relieve the department of the
liability and the burden of having to
maintain thank you any any questions for
the
Department seeing none senders there
motion move to
approve senders move to approve item
23029 seconded by I'll second represent
discussion if you're in favor of the
motion to approve uh item
23029 uh sign IFI by saying I I I any
unanimous so we will move on to item
23030 Department of
Transportation requests approval dispose
of a parcel of unimproved state-owned
land consisting of 5.2 Acres uh
southwesterly side in Hampshire 106 and
easterly of Lowden Ridge Road Town of uh
len
by listing agreement
please thank you Mr uh Mr chairman the
uh the department is seeking
authorization to uh dispose of the
subject property which is made up of 5.2
acres of land in the town of Lowden it
was purchased for the uh laon uh
conquered Laconia
bypass we're seeking will be asking
999,000 plus the 1100
um dollar administrative fee I
can I can answer any further questions
this certainly vacant land y questions
Department move to approve um Senator
Lang motion to approve uh seconded by
represent cluder any further discussion
if you're in favor of the motion um to
approve uh
2330 um signified by saying I I I any
opposed seeing none carries
unanimous we will move to item
23032 Department transportation request
authorization sell .06 of an acre State
own land within the right of way located
on the Westerly side of Shadow Lake Road
Town of
Salem
um directly to I cannot pronounce that
37,1 uh if you would
sir thank you Mr chairman uh the subject
property is 0.006 of an acre uh in the
town of Salem it really only has any
value to the grantee it was purchased as
a turnaround for Shadow Lake Road which
at the time was in intended to be a
deadend road uh it was purchased as part
of a larger parcel which was just over
half an acre purchased uh at
450,000 for the Windom Salem project the
parcel we're selling is 006 of an acre
and as I said if you were actually out
there looking at it you wouldn't even
realize that this parcel is a separate
parcel with the group Fe all right quick
question yes please Senator so was this
in a butter is that some butach it that
has
development uh uses for it I'm like 06
Acres you're not putting much on it
so any further questions move to approve
um motion to approve by the senator Lang
seconded by represent I'll second again
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion 2303 two uh
signified by saying I I I any
unanimous um Department of
Transportation item
23033 requests authorization to sell
15.6 Acres state owned land located on
the easly side of the Everett Turnpike
to the town of hooks it directly to the
Raymond Richmond
company um if you would sir
thank you Mr chairman the property is uh
the department is seeking authorization
to sell the 5.56 Acres uh to um directly
to the Richmond company for
145,000 which includes the
administrative fee uh the parcel itself
is landlocked and would only have any
value to I believe what is three part
what is three Butters so when it became
when it was valued um it was valued as
part of a larger parcel method um it
really has no value on the open market
because it has no access to any internal
roads and we'll have no access to the at
the ever
turnpike so it's again like I said it's
only value
to thank you I can take any questions
yes R sanberger uh the question I have
thank you Mr chairman uh is this is this
5.6 I'm reading 15 point oh okay very
good thank you any further any further
questions I'm sorry you Lang reading
something is there a reason this isn't
going to the open market first is it
just because a because it has no value
on the open market that like um there's
only three abing Parcels that it has
actually any use for that would have
actually any use for
it okay any further questions seeing
none Senator move to approve um senator
Lang moves to approve seconded by the
second again per clue there thank you
discussion seeing none if you're in
favor of the motion uh
2333 signified by saying I I I any
opposed motion carries
you we will move to item
23031 Department of Natural and cultural
resources request authorization
long-term lease US Cellular on proposed
120 foot monopole for cellular antenna
array um on Federal Hill in Goffstown
New
Hampshire please introduce yourself sir
morning Mr chairman and committee my
name is Benjamin Yos I'm the
communications program coordinator for
the Department of Natural culture Cal
resources and we are looking for
authorization to enter into a long-term
lease with US Cellular on a proposed 120
foot monopole um and antenna array and
ground space for a penon enclosure
supporting the Telecommunications
equipment at Federal Hill in
gtown uh US Cellular will be
constructing the Tower and the
supporting services and receiving a
beneficial consideration from the state
at a reduced rent for the first 10 years
of up to $120,000 or half of the the
project costs whichever is less uh the
proposed lease rate for the first year
is
$44,000 roughly $
44,0 32 with a 3% increase each year
over the first 10 years less $112,000
per year for a total of
$384,000
64328 in Revenue over the first 10 years
the lease will be expected to take
effects effect uh the first of the
fiscal year July 1st 2024 uh follow
following the first 10 years there will
be a lesie option for two more 5-year
lease agreements at which point the
state would then own the cell tower so
Federal Hill right now all the equipment
is on the fire tower so the antennas and
then we have an older concrete
Communications building at the bottom of
the tower housing all of us so that
would all get cleaned up the towers will
the antennas will come off of the fire
tower which is slated to get rehab next
year and the fenced in area will then
contain all the equipment on concrete
paths so it cleans up the area for
people hiking up there puts it in one
section the fire tower goes back to
normal so we feel it's a a good deal for
the for the state for dncr if if I could
this this Arrangement that you're using
on these these pay schedules for X
number of years yes is that similar to
other locations you've done previously
yes currently they're a tenant there now
so this next fiscal year would kick off
their 3% increase for what they're
currently paying now but this does
mirror what we're doing in other
places thank you any
questions move to approve um motion to
approve by Sandra Lang seconded
by represent CL thank you uh any further
discussion if you're in favor of that
motion signify by saying I I any opposed
seeing none motion carries unanimous
thank you thank you Mr chairman
item uh lrcp
23023 Department of
Transportation uh request authorization
easement for electric transmission wires
over parcel land average 10 feet in
length 99 in withth of state owned
Mountain division railroad Corridor town
of what's it lunenberg
Vermont
to
continue
good morning uh chairman and members of
the committee I'm Lewis Barker from the
Bureau of rail and Transit Department of
Transportation here to present a
proposed easement to Granite State power
partners for an electric uh transmission
line over the railroad quar uh Granite
State power Partners acquired a lease or
has a lease with the abing uh paper mill
property owners for a solar array and to
connect to the uh power grid they have
to to cross the uh railroad rway to get
to the nearest uh Town Road
um we previously entered into a Crossing
agreement but the grand state power
Partners Financial support uh insists on
a longer term agreement so we're here to
request a long-term easement which will
property any other questions if if I
could and then I'll open up so how how
long is how long is that term a minimum
of 25 years but there is a renewal
Clause so if I could your this agreement
is overhead over the top yes
sir okay uh represent CL you have
question thank you Mr chairman in the
first paragraph under requested action I
just want to be clear about this
something about you wanted a one-time
administ a fee of
$1,100 of which the department is in
receipt of $500 is that an that's that's
correct this is the payment that you've
already got towards that $1,100 yes sir
okay so in other words they would only
owe us if we approve this item today
$600 is that cor yes all right thank you
thank you Mr further
questions Mr Barker yes represent V uh
thank you Mr chairman uh just want to
keep it straight uh who are the partners
that this is uh is it Green Street or
Granite State or I misspoke it's green
State okay thank
you further uh further questions Mr
Barker seeing none Senator do you have a
motion move to approve uh Senator moves
to approve item
2323 um if you're I'll second that
motion
Mr seconded by represent cluder uh any
further discuss discussion seeing none
if you're favor that uh that motion
23023 signified by saying I I I any
opposed seeing none carries
you
um okay we will move to um item um
2334 community college system New
Hampshire requests approval to sell two
Parcels of surplus land in Berlin
consisting of 1.53 acres of land in a
single story Ranch Residential Building
approximately 2800 square
feet um at 15 tal Lane
for and if Gentlemen please introduce
proposal I just push the red button push
there we
go good morning um good morning my name
is Matthew Moore I'm the director of
capital Planning and Development uh with
the community college system and with me
I have President Chuck Lloyd um to help
answer any questions with the um
property
disposal um yeah we're here to um ask
permission to sell um the two properties
uh adjacent to the uh properties we just
sold um a couple of years ago
um it's like you said that there ones on
twitchel Lane and one the other ones on
Riverside
Drive um these properties were donated
to the um college and um they fall um
but they fall into the uh 188
F6 um Ral um
13A um so we need prior permission of
the long range capital budget
utilization committee and governing
Council um for the right of first
refusal um in any proposed sale of the
real property um both properties were uh
acquired before the effective date
um August 19th um
um your jurisdiction is from what I
understand the right to sale but um as
you like typically know what the
appraisal rates are um the
U twitchel Lane property was assessed at
215,000 and the Riverside Drive property
is at 40,000 the twitchell lane property
used to be a child care um now storage
with a garage um the Riverside Drive
property is um has been used it's a old
cap has been used for uh storage mostly
um when it references uh in the document
attached garage it's actually just the
foundation Remains the other part is
fallen down and we've taken care of that
both properties uh are in dire need of
um um work and uh this would help the
college by disposing of the property and
not have to to maintain these
properties we we request the commission
to sell this property thank you Mr Moore
questions yes Senator just to be clear
that it looks like both these Parcels
were acquired by the community college
but no cost as a grant from a private
individual that was given to the
Community College and now we're
disposing of them because you have no
use for them that is correct that's
correct right now it's uh it's really an
upkeep of you know we don't want to
throw good money at bad both the proper
properties are are in disarray we're
using them as cold storage we no longer
have that need and they were a gift to
the college thank you Senator before I
take the motion so um when we're dealing
with the State Surplus lands and monies
that we had acquired from the federal
government we understand where that
money is going tell me so if this moves
forward and you were to uh receive
$250,000 for these two Parcels uh what
what is the intent of that money
thank you for the question Mr chair uh
really to reinvest right back into the
college you know to work with uh student
services academic supports and any
infrastructure we would need at the
college really trying to right siize and
and uh focus on the the primary uh
College
location thank you any further questions
Senator move to approve uh Senator Lang
moves to approve uh seconded by I will
second by represent cluder any further
discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
motion for item
23034 uh signified by saying I I any
opposed motion carries unanimous thank
you um thank you uh we'll move to our
last uh item here 23035 community
college system of New Hampshire requests
approval to sell Surplus land in
Bennington New Hampshire one unimproved
one improved parcel approximately 1.4
acres along gills uh gills Hill
Road um gentlemen Mr Moore thank you Mr
chair um with me today today on this
parcel I have the president Brian mcdell
president of the Manchester Community
College and also um in the background um
I forgot to mention before uh Jared nyen
from Department of administrative
Services if we have any questions on the
process of
188f Welcome gentlemen go ahead sir this
proess 1.4 acres uh in Bennington was
donated to the Manchester Community
College um and uh resides on Gillis Hill
Road um and we have no um need um for
the property um as the um construction
program of Manchester Community College
has um
no long is no longer there um it was um
donated as a no cost gift um again this
property as well um was um prior to um
2011 um was of
1994 um so that it falls under the 180
f-6 um disposal of the property um um
13A and requires approval of long range
capital budget utilization for the sale
of this property um and I had uh the
property appraised and the appraisal
came back at
$40,000 um and um so for the for that
point um we have um we asked for
permission to be able to sell this
property thank you Mr
Moore ready for a motion um motion
Senator please move to approve uh motion
made by Senator Lang to approve uh
seconded by I'll second it okay good
Chain Break chain oh you broke my rhythm
[Laughter]
now so um any further discussion before
we call if you're in favor of the motion
um for 2303 35 signified by saying I I I
any opposed motion carries unanimous
thank you gentl thank you Mr chair and
committee I see item four miscellaneous
we have no materials uh item five is
informational which is on
23024 on Hampshire Council of resources
and
development if um if the committee were
a little tight on time um we'll take
that and consider that and if there
questions we'll bring that
back um we are if I remember right Mr
Shay we were looking at December 15th is
our next meeting
date uh December 15th at 9:30 9:30 I'm
I'm sorry Mr chair yes is anybody from
Bea
here on those informational items was
anybody here if I had a I wanted to sure
is there someone here I don't believe
there is I'll reach out to commissioner
casell okay Cor okay sounds good all
right I was interested in the
conversation around the renaming of
Mount Washington that was in this bill
that's in these minutes so that's
all so are you going to speak directly
or would you like someone to come
forward I'll speak
directly could you uh update us Che let
me know how that goes and um so the next
the next date unless there's uh we have
problem with a quum be December 15 at
9:30 so Mr Shay anything else we missed
I got one
minute all right thank you uh we will
call move to adjourn motion Mills
seconded by to adjourn and we will take
up um on the an extra minute in two
minutes we will begin our next uh
gentlemen